tras años de turbulencias un gran logro
diplomático para ambos países la
reanudación de las relaciones con
turquía es un recurso importante para la
estabilidad regional y una noticia
económica muy importante para los
ciudadanos de israel
el gobierno de israel anunció la noticia
tras una llamada entre el primer
ministro israelí yair lapid y el
presidente turco recep tayip erdogán
ambos acordaron volver a enviar
embajadores en los países respectivos
turquía defensor de los derechos del
pueblo palestino prometió que no
abandonaría a palestina
continuaremos defendiendo los derechos
de palestina jerusalén y gaza y es
importante que nuestros mensajes sean
enviados directamente a que la vida se
vive sin dt fueron aliados pero los
lazos diplomáticos entre ankara y tel
aviv se rompieron en mayo de 2010 cuando
el barco de pasajeros mavi marmara parte
de la flotilla de la libertad que
llevaba ayuda a gaza intentó atravesar
el bloqueo naval que impone israel ante
la franja soldados israelíes abordaron
la nave en aguas internacionales mataron
a 10 personas e hirieron a 60 las
tensiones se relajaron en breve en 2016
cuando israel pagó millones de dólares
en compensación a las familias de las
víctimas mortales del incidente sin
embargo la relación se volvió a enfriar
cuando eeuu reconoció jerusalén como
capital de israel en 2017
erdogán reaccionó retirando al embajador
turco de israel tras una visita
determinante del presidente israelí
isaac herzog a ankara en marzo ambos
países se volcaron en los intereses que
les unen como aumentar el comercio
bilateral y cooperar en el desarrollo de
un gaseoducto en el mediterráneo
oriental